the bushwhacker
on the podcast luke thank you for
blessing us with your presents today
well g'day danny it's bloody good to be
here mate
you're looking good mate but you smell
like sardines and i've had that for
breakfast for many years
have you really you i've known you for a
long time you used to run the gym on
clearwater beach uh
florida beach yeah you had your own gym
we used to always work out together me
you and the hulkster and those were some
good times
some good times mate that evolution of
time we have to move on you gotta move
on
yeah every once in a while you gotta
just move on and write a new chapter
exactly mate and i'm moving on i don't
know what the next chapter
is going to be but um well i've got a
few ideas anyhow
have you yeah so how you been how are
you good good mate good
i just got back from quebec a town
i worked in a town on sunday afternoon
it's the first time i've been there
since 1972.
that was the last time i wrestled in
that town and i had a few people there
came up to me they were old
they said i remember you being here yeah
many many moons ago
with andre the giant that's crazy so
you're
how old are you now hey
brian i'm i of the girls out there
i'm 25 26. you don't look a day over 30.
no no any um 73 at christmas january
and you're still wrestling you're still
in the ring entertaining
wow you could call it it's called
entertaining
why is it called entertaining well
that's what i do i entertain the people
is that what everyone calls it is that
what all of wwe
wwe it's called wwe is
world wrestling entertainment okay so
it's just you don't call it wrestling
people just call it no you could call it
wrestling it's
wrestling and that but um when they look
at me and they say you still recognize
i'm entertaining right right sounds
better at my age
you don't do any kind of like hard jumps
or take any big bumps
i give them you give them you give them
i'm a giver
not a taker remember that folks
and all you women out there
whoa what whoa from down under
you know what i mean and i'm a bush
whacker
where'd you get hate being told most of
them tell me today but i'm shaved
most the woman when i say i'm from down
under and i'm a bushwhacker they turn
around and say to me
well i'm shaved oh the women say that to
you yeah
that's hilarious so where did so where
did you come up i mean
so we've had the pleasure of having many
wwe superstars on this show we've had
jimmy hart
we've had lanny poffo the brother of
macho man
and now you're the third wwe superstar
um so how did you get into the business
like
can you let's talk about like your early
days where are you from how many days
how did you get started in this crazy
wacky world
funny but it's the next door neighbor
this i was in a
born in a town called lower heart new
zealand
it's a suburb of the capital wellington
it's about eight miles out from from the
city of wellington
yeah and my next-door neighbor
was a bodybuilder and uh
he went into mr new zealand and that and
he got placed
and the judge in mr new zealand
was a former mr new zealand in 1950
mr new zealand he was a judge plus
he at this time now he was the um
wrestling promoter for the only
promotion in new zealand
and he said to my uh next door neighbor
my buddy
he said to him you know why not make
some money with that body
so my neighbor's name was brian
brian ashby so he went into the gym it
was in wellington
you know eight six or eight miles away
and it was
the gym was like the gym in the first
rocky movie if you ever remember that
the steam pipes rattling
it had a steam room the old the old
school gym
the only two machines that had were or
racks that had was
was a bench press and a squat rack all
the rest were kettlebells
and freeways laying around the floor and
there was two rings there
20 by 20 rings the floor the floor of
the rings were hard as a floor
as this room or harder the payment on
the roads around here
and um the boxing rings four ropes
and they were and the wrestling rings
were four ropes two in new zealand
at that time it was uh and they were
the governed the wrestling rings our
resting shows were governed by the
police
and they came and checked the rings
before to make sure
it was 20 feet by 20 feet in the ropes
now
what the hell does that mean you know
what i mean
if was 18 feet right but [ __ ] police
came
and and checked and measured it and
everybody too
had to put the promoter to put
everyone's name in
uh two months ahead of the show to see
if they had any criminal record
this is how it was the police the police
sat ringside
and if you did anything illegal they
hopped up in the ring
there was no punch when i uh anyhow
there was no punching
and no kicking so it was either forearms
or
the british under uppercut and and you
could do a knee drop
anyhow that's crazy how so how old were
you when you got into this
15 or just turning 16. anyhow how i got
it
i he said to me arty he was going for
about a month
and he says why not come in there i was
175
wet 175 pound wet at the time
and um i started going in there to the
gym with him
about six months down the line i went to
my first wrestling match
live wrestling match and one of the
opponents didn't arrive
in the in the in the light will um
junior heavyweight a light heavyweight
and that next minute i got a pair of
boots thrown at me
and a tank top thrown at me i had jeans
on
and that's how i went to the ring and
don't ask me
about the match because it's a blank
that was my first match ever the arena
was full
it was you know 3 000 people at that
time
you know i'm talking about 1962 yeah in
little old new zealand
where they roll up the the sidewalks at
six o'clock
at night you know the bars close to six
everything wow just to go downtown any
little townships
uh 6 37 you you're lucky to find a caf
cafeteria open in any of the smaller
cities
in the capital you'd find them but in
the smaller cities the sidewalks were
rolled up
and the lights are out really the blinds
were down
that's wild yeah we didn't have it and
we didn't we
everyone sat around a radio at home
listening to soap operas on radio
we never never got television until um
67
and it would start at three in the
afternoon and finish at eight or nine
o'clock at night
that's how when we first got crazy ah
that's some crazy [ __ ] we were 20 years
ago
we were 20 years behind the states and
and behind aussie at the time too
you know what were you doing in new
zealand this whole time so you're
checking sheep
that's all you did was shag sheep no no
no i'm an engineer by trade or
eternal fitter you know lathe work
and and um with a you know turning um
steel with a lathe and doing welding
arch and arc
uh arc welding argon arc uh gas
gas brazing and and all that sort of
stuff
yeah dealing with steel putting stuff
together okay so that's what you did for
a living when you first yeah i was i did
a
i did an apprenticeship okay i did the
ten thousand hours
that's a five year i did a lot of
overtime
and i did it in four years but meantime
in the meanwhile
i was wrestling two because i'd finish
work at four and then
in new zealand you can
hop on a plane from the capitol and you
can be at the end of the other island
or over in the south island anywhere
within an hour
you know once you're on the plane
everything is close
the islands new zealand consists of two
islands 600 miles long
each and each about 150 miles wide
so that's it and we're way down south
for you people out there don't know
where we are
we're south southeast of australia and
below
us is south pole
have got a base in the south island and
the southern
the south island where they take go down
to the south pole you know what i mean
yeah wow did you ever go to the south
pole no never
never never flowing it's two hours from
christchurch
and that's you two and a half hours and
you're over
people fly over tourists americans go
down there
and they go on the charters and they fly
over the south pole
i better see you we're a mountainous
country what you call mountains over
here
we call hills our mountains are forty
from twelve thousand feet to twenty
thousand feet
you